alors ce n'est pas le seul élément mais
il va retenir l'attention c'est un
télécabine donc du port ici auprès de
vos jusqu'à la citadelle
effectivement c'est un élément de ce
projet global mais pas seulement
ce projet global qu'on porte vraiment
quatre poules vraiment très très
intéressant que ce soit l'espace nature
et port de plaisance que nous
retrouverons sur les prés de vaux avec
le développement donc d'une maison des
sports des sports nature et le départ de
leur vélo route avec l'installation de
stations de vélos sur sur cet espace un
pôle vraiment touristique cette fois-ci
toujours sur les prés de vaux avec une
liaison entre les prés de vaux et la
citadelle pour avoir ce continuum entre
le haut et le bas avec un télécabine qui
sera installé pour arriver derrière donc
la citadelle un pôle aussi sur tout ce
qui est sport et évasion nous pourrons
liés l'arrière de la citadelle en
direction de la chapelle début par le
dsas est à l'étude d'un pont d'un pont
en bois pour relancer en direction des
espaces ce trailer randonnée et de
développer un parcours aventure nous
retrouverons tyrolienne via ferrata est
également un groupe accrobranche et puis
un quatrième pôle un quatrième pôle
cette fois ci sur la citadelle où nous
souhaitons emmener donc les touristes
dans un voyage au travers notre
patrimoine où nous pourrons bien sûr
réorienter le musée le muséum en tout
cas de l'espace animalier parce qu'il
faut travailler autour de cela pour
avoir des espèces aujourd'hui plus en
adéquation avec notre notre territoire
et puis travailler sur la réalité
augmentée pour pouvoir emmener donc les
visiteurs au travers notre patrimoine au
travers la construction besançon au
travers le
la rivière le doubs à laquelle on tourne
le dos trop trop souvent et donc c'est
pouvoir réhabiliter l'ensemble de ses
espaces là d'avoir vraiment cette
liaison entre ces quatre sets 4
connexions et j'en oublie pas non plus
bien sûr en finale le coeur des villes
nos coeur historique qui sera lié par
une navette électrique entre les prés de
vaux et le coeur historique donc tout
cela fera vraiment ce projet global de
besançon pour pouvoir re dynamiser
l'attractivité de notre territoire avec
un objectif qui est de développer
notamment sur l'axé citadelle à plus de
50%
c'est un projet que l'on souhaite
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que la
citadelle c'est à peu près de 180 mille
visiteurs en moyenne sur les dix
dernières années l'unesco ne nous a pas
forcément permis aujourd'hui de pouvoir
franchir un certain seuil contrairement
à arras quand on a travaillé un petit
peu sur ce qui se faisait sur les réseau
des sites majeurs vauban et donc ce
n'est pas si à 420 milles visiteurs sur
la citadelle avec ce projet global que
nous souhaitons développer et bien sûr
c'est surtout aussi créateur d'emplois
qui eux ne sont pas délocalisables
vous avez chiffré votre projet notamment
le télécabine
on a chiffré à chiffrer l'ensemble de
ceux de ce projet on nous sommes
beaucoup appuyé sur ce qui a pu se
construire à brest puisque vous savez
brest et sur un téléphérique donc ce
sont des choses quatre sont un petit peu
différente en terme de technicité mais
il faut savoir que nous sommes entre 12
et 15 millions d'euros sur cet
investissement global sur sur le
territoire mais avec derrière un
retentissement est en tout cas une
résonance pour notre territoire bisontin
de grande envergure au niveau national
et international
parce que le risque aujourd'hui c'est ce
n'est pas le côté le coup mais ces deux
le risque c'est de développer des
politiques qui ne sont pas cohérentes et
cette cohérence là que nous souhaitons
développer pour le développement
économique pour le score pour la culture
pour le lien social pour nos familles eh
bien nous le retrouvons dans ce projet
d'envergure de port cette année